ми їх україна та наша система вас
ветошкіна і не посипаємо в голову по підлозі
бо у нас їжу шипова тату сірчаний
це показало наш прогрес у чому сі там
вже секс-шопа ременя ти наші результати
бірж його ким су та draw them суми
просунулась вперед наша проблема і
чому я прогнозу view що далі
краще
bizim вже стати таким стартом дим і
побачимо оранка проблем які я звільнився
виливаючи в тому, що поки що наше
мовчання у школі орієнтована на
репродукцію знань на цілий ринт ванни
знизу зовнішнього на закладеного
оцінювання тому що за зовні
національного києва не вигляд дзеркалі цей
шум взяти школі і нам поки що школі вчать
чому потім що вимагає на цьому вони
цьому ми розминаємо у пізу я графік 1 ст
вже корисливих інструментів для нас я
все-таки рухайся в системі оцінювання та
стані зми стільця і ​​в суміші його свити
простоватість самий the complete and не
знову підходу в на вч вони там і я теж
с одягаються що це буде довідки
взаємовигідно спиць брати і ми з вами
стоїмо на порозі сил із прямого нам уру
ху з реформування свити заради блага
наших українських дітей